there is collective brain damage
happening across the world right now
right in front of our faces
let's be clear she he them are bananas
those people are insane you don't have
to behave the way these people want
people they have no understanding of
what it is to get and earn respect and
to be an adult in a world that doesn't
have to bow to you the woke thing is a
parasite and when it's in the system
every system that we've seen it in it
destroys that system it's why everything
is melting down
[Music]
good morning turning point how you guys
doing today
glad to see you guys bright and early on
this sunday i am very happy to be here i
realized on the way i actually took a
three and a half hour drive at about uh
midnight last night from the other coast
uh i realized this is probably my my
sixth or seventh turning point event and
i used to come
as sort of the the why i left the left
guy oh that guy was a progressive he
woke up and i think this is pretty much
the first turning point i've done
where i can say that
i'm one of you guys i am a conservative
i'm very proud to be a conservative i'll
i'll talk a little bit about what i
think that means but even better than
that ladies and gentlemen i am also
a proud new floridian yeah
that's right
i got out of crazy commie california i
tried i tried to recall gavin newsom my
campaigned with the great larry elder we
tried to make it happen
yeah but these people want it they want
big government they want high taxes they
want the crime they want their sons to
be daughters they want their non-racists
to be racist they just want more and
more and more and now i live in florida
with the iguanas and the peacocks and
the lizards and the gators and i
absolutely love it it is it is a spirit
of freedom you know people
people keep asking me well what's the
main difference okay you lived in cali
now you live in florida
what's the main difference and it's not
really the obvious stuff sure the
obvious stuff is obvious okay i'm not
living around homeless encampments i
don't see drugs everywhere
the roads aren't falling apart all of
that is obvious i got a little more
money in my pocket because we have no
income tax here okay fine but it's
something else it's something else it's
actually i think probably something you
guys have seen a lot of over the last
two or three days here which is that
people are happy here people are
genuinely happy you see a light in their
eyes you see a feeling of oh it's bad
over there but it's not bad over here so
i am truly the the happiest new
floridian that you will find and i i'm
so appreciative i always you know when
you're a new floridian because they're
getting hundreds literally hundreds of
thousands of people coming here to
florida and the ogs the original
floridians they kind of look at us like
uh oh you know are you gonna bring all
that blue state nonsense and i walk
around in my neighborhood i'll have my
dog and i've taken a walk and neighbors
will come up and i try to say hi to
everybody and they'll say well where are
you from
and i go well actually i came from
california i used to live in los angeles
and they kind of freak out for a second
and then usually i just take out a
picture of me and desantis and then
we're good because they get it they get
it that's my governor yeah
yeah so look there's a lot happening in
the world i i mentioned sort of this new
idea of conservatism right this new idea
and it's it's kind of funny because you
guys especially for those of you that
are that are college age you are growing
up in a seriously wacky time it was not
like this i'm i'm not that old i'm 46.
that may sound kind of old to some of
you i grew up before playstation so that
is a little weird but
i grew up in a time
when it was it was kind of set it was
kind of said oh america's good things
kind of work you know you just do what
you want to do live how you want to live
you're going to be okay and you guys
have grown up basically in this insane
time fueled of course
by algorithms and big tech and tick tock
and all of the nonsense fueled by
everything that we used to accept as
real and true
is no longer true right your body parts
don't match your gender all all of the
stuff two plus two is now five
everything that five years ago we would
have said is true is now under assault
and it's on you guys to have to fix that
thing so when i come up here and i say
well i'm a conservative now it's like
well what what does that mean and we can
agree on okay we want states rights we
want low taxes we believe in individual
rights we believe that the the founding
of america was just and good and decent
and
from where i stand i mean this is the
greatest country in the history of the
world 250 years
it really is you know we say that i'm
sure i'm not the first speaker to say
that at a turning point event and if you
think that it really is true it really
is true every single one of you have it
better than your parents did and your
parents had it better than their parents
and the parents before them every single
person in this room your ancestors came
from somewhere basically with nothing
and they made it here and nobody cares
this is the thing this is the the real
devil that the the left and the
progressives and the media have put into
the system
nobody really cares what your skin color
is
nobody really cares what your gender is
or your sexuality is or any of that
nonsense
and that was that was a hard one for me
to fully realize because you know when i
was when i was on the left and i was a
democrat it's like it is so programmed
into you right i have no doubt that you
guys as as young conservatives if that's
what you call yourself or libertarians
or whatever it might be you guys are the
outliers right at your college right i'm
pretty sure that most of you there might
be two or three schools uh that you're
not the outlier where you go there and
you say what you believe or maybe you
don't say what you believe i know that's
a big thing you know everyone's afraid
to say what they believe because they
want to get the grade but if you stand
up for what you believe if you stand up
for just basic honest truth
you're assaulted and
that's what i now believe a new
conservative movement is it's like there
is a there is a sanity movement in this
country and we can disagree on okay
maybe we want the marginal tax rate to
be this or that and maybe we have some
slight disagreements on foreign policy
or whatever but there's roughly a sanity
party the republican party
and then there is a completely insane
party and that's what unfortunately
through the algorithms and and media and
just general cultural nonsense that is
what the left has pushed on everybody so
that's what we're fighting against
that's what we're fighting against and
those little differences
i don't think they matter that much i
really don't think they matter it's like
if you believe that individual rights
are important that you should be judged
and treated based on your actions on
your thoughts on your words if you
believe that everyone in this country
doesn't matter whether you came from
cuba or from india or from africa it
just doesn't matter if you come here and
you're a hard-working citizen who obeys
the laws and works hard to to better
your life and better your kid's life and
all that stuff it's like
that's what we have in america and guess
what that is that is incredibly special
right that is unbelievably special no
other nation in the history of the world
was ever founded by that and what the
left has done with all of this woke
stuff with all of this identity politics
stuff they've tried to literally strip
that away and as i often say you know
it's like you got to give the devil his
due they have done an incredible job we
may think
that aoc is an idiot or that bernie's
just some old socialist fool or that joe
biden is eating pudding and all of that
stuff but it's like man
look what these guys accomplished right
they tore down a whole bunch of stuff
but
and this is the beauty
look what's starting to happen there
there is a massive pushback on this
stuff right i mean governor ron desantis
who was here a couple days ago i mean
what did he do he walked into orlando
and stared down mickey mouse and he won
i mean he won you know
do you know that disney has lost 61
billion dollars since ron desantis took
him on
[Applause]
you don't want to know what donald duck
is doing for a hot lunch these days just
wandering around in orlando it ain't
pretty it ain't pretty
it's a little early to work blue i know
um
but that's what's happening now it's
like people are fighting back right
people are saying enough's enough good
people are getting on school boards and
saying get this woke stuff out people
are moving right people are moving
across the country this is a beautiful
thing people think it's kind of weird
it's like well wait a minute should you
stay and fight should you is there a way
to fix california fix new york fix
illinois is there a way to do it
and i tried and many people do try but
that in america you have the ability to
get up and go and go find a place with
greener pastures go find a place that is
more in line with your values and then
strengthen that place that's exactly
what i'm trying to do right here in
florida and that's why gavin newsom
who is genuinely evil and i'm fairly
certain soulless that's why gavin newsom
is now the number one
u-haul salesman in america because
something
something like 200 000 people have fled
california
but this is the beauty of the american
system this is the beauty of federalism
and states rights it's like you know if
you live in most countries in the world
almost every country including almost
every western country like canada and
like britain you know they don't have
this idea of states rights the idea that
the local governments should have far
more to do with your life than the
federal government so if you don't like
justin trudeau up in canada who has
become one of the worst authoritarian
leaders in the world guess what whether
you live in toronto or calgary it
doesn't matter that much if you move
from one or the other
yeah a little bit with your mayor but
basically trudeau has complete control
over that country but in america you can
still get up and go and i can tell you
as a new floridian i live in a different
country i live in the country that we
all thought we lived in and i don't know
that we can do anything about cali so if
they want it
they can have it and and i know that
kind of oh what does that mean
and are we going to split up and what is
all of that well look we're the we're
the united states as long as we're
united right and we have to figure out
what brings us together but in the
meantime i think i think you build new
things you build you build not build
back better
you just build new things you go okay
if the institutions are crumbling if the
universities are crumbling
if you guys are going to schools where
they're teaching you what to think and
not how to think if you're afraid to say
what you think
you know i know a lot of people
especially it's like you're 19 20 years
old uh it's tough it's tough to say what
you think right you don't want your
friends to turn on you you don't want
you don't want it the teacher not to
give you the good grade and all of that
stuff uh but you got to do it you got to
do it you live truly even despite all
this lunacy you live in the freeze place
ever
unimaginably free place just everyone
think you're thinking your grandparents
everyone in this room
you're doing better than they are as i
said you're doing better than they are
and you live in a freer world now
something screwy something screwy after
two years of lockdowns after two years
of saying violence when you burn down
buildings is okay
uh after two years of calling everybody
a nazi and all that stuff but we still
have something great here and you still
have a way to do it uh and as many of
you guys know i i toured for about a
year and a half with the great jordan
peterson who has uh yeah
i gotta tell you every time i mention
jordan's name and people plot i
genuinely get chills up my spine because
i saw that man on that tour that we did
uh about 120 stops 20 countries i saw
this guy set order in the world we live
in a chaotic world but i saw this one
man just start saying what he believed
and and thinking it through and being
careful with his words and saying here i
am on this planet as an individual as a
human being i'm going to say what i
think and by doing that
he then started making other people do
it and for those of you that applauded
right there he probably did a little
something for you i know he did an awful
lot for me and i stand up straight with
my shoulders back my room is clean and
all of that stuff
and jordan
often would say
when college students would ask this was
one of the main questions we would get
during the q a they would say well you
know i'm in school
and my teacher is a lefty and they've
given me an assignment and you know i
want to get the grade and i want to be
able to get to grad school or get the
the job i want put this thing on my
resume so you know what do i do do i do
i say what i believe
you know say i'm an economics class and
they want me to write about socialism
but i believe in capitalism which has
freed more people than any other
financial system in the world over yeah
capitalism it's good it's good
honestly equally trading with people
where everyone can win it's pretty sweet
so what do you do and jordan said
something very interesting because i
know a lot of people will say a lot of
public people will tell young people oh
you know what if it's just school and
it's a class that doesn't matter that
much you know just uh just write the
paper just do what you got to do to keep
moving through the system
but jordan actually took the other
approach and and i really believe this
and it's something i've tried to
incorporate in my life whether whether
you're in school or not just how you
operate in the world
which is that if
you are in school you guys 18 19 years
old you have virtually no
responsibilities right like you have
almost nothing to to worry about other
than the social pressures and if you go
in to school
that first time that you write that
paper
where you don't say what you think or
you blatantly write something that
absolutely is against what you think
that's the hardest time
and then after that you will do it again
whether it's in school or with your
family or with your friends or whatever
it is and you will do it again and again
and again and then four years later from
a freshman to a senior you will not even
remember
the person that you were when you worked
in school
and that really is my main message to
you guys especially those of you that
are in school you have an awesome
opportunity to fight for a better world
the world is upside down right now and
that's scary but it's also opportunity
it's like you can really do something
special but you can only do something
special if you're willing to stand up to
the machine and say here i am and i'm
not gonna just bow because you demand me
to bow so that's why i'm always so proud
to come to the turning point events
that's why i'm proud to be here with you
guys that's why i'm proud to be a
floridian
and uh we got about five minutes left so
if any of you have questions i always
like doing the q a i know you guys got
some good stuff so just run up to the
mics and we'll try to do as many as
possible
and keep this state free and all that
good stuff all right do we have some
questions over there hi my name is cokey
um
i love you so much me and my mom watch
the urban report religiously oh thanks
my question for you is what are the main
reasons that you made the transition
from a classical liberal to a
conservative and what exactly do you
think that means
well as thomas seoul said to me uh facts
that that really is it that really is it
that really is it you know i would say
you're actually asking a really good
question because you specifically said
classical liberal and not liberal or
leftist to a conservative i would say
one of the things that's been very hard
for me
over the last couple of years is my
first book don't burn this book was a
defense of classical liberalism which is
really the the founding principles of
this nation individual rights
laissez-faire economics states rights
rule of law things of that nature and
unfortunately the liberals of today you
guys know this the liberals of today do
not believe in this stuff they did
believe in this stuff there were old
school good liberals jfk was a liberal
jfk who wanted to cut taxes who wanted
to not go to war jfk who said ask not
what your country can do for you ask
what you can do for your country that is
the complete reverse of the liberal
message of today so as i saw that
and then i started talking to these guys
that i thought were were scary and mean
you know ben shapiro people are afraid
of ben shapiro he's four foot six he's
not that scary
people are afraid of glenn beck people
are afraid afraid of larry elder of
dennis prager of jordan peterson i
started talking to these guys and while
we maybe had some marginal political
differences i realized that they were
fighting for the right things and those
things were things that they were trying
to conserve that people before them had
conserved so that's why i was able to
make the move and still stand here all
right we've got a couple minutes left
i'll try to go i'll try to go quick all
right um so
first of all i love jordan peterson um
but i moved from boston to texas um last
year and so here everyone says you know
be involved in politics this should be
your life but in boston i had a hub
and i was obsessed with politics looking
at it constantly i was not happy
and i was miserable and it was horrible
and i feel what is your suggestion to
people who just
like it's either their politics or their
life got it
yeah it's a great question i would say
this politics should not be your life
government should be so small that it
can't do everything you want and it
can't take everything from you you know
partly
partly what the what the left did here
was they made everything about politics
right they wake up and what can we fight
about and what can the government do and
all of these things and they believe in
essence that the government is god that
everything that is right in front of you
on any given day that that is the truth
and that is real and that's why you must
fight and at the same time you got to
fight nazis and by god all of your
political opponents are nazis and it's
all just nonsense so whether your
framework for living
outside of that is through religion or
philosophy or whatever works for you or
your family unit you have to have
something that sits much bigger that
politics is just right inside of but the
day that they trick us all to think that
politics is the answer to everything is
the day we lose we got time for time for
one more all right well i got a quick
one so you might actually get two and
all right i tried to ask the same
question to miss cat yesterday but i'mma
say it to you now can i get a hug yes
you can get the one second hug i offer
the one second hug to people you'll have
to find me though i can't jump off the
stage and hug you
uh okay one more we got one more
um hi my name is gavin erhard from west
virginia this is kind of a crazy
question but um
um
what would you um are you if i may ask
this are you gay i heard you were gay
now my husband's gay okay
well
i i'm i'm sorry but this is the reason
why i ask
as i i'm a christian and one thing that
really draws me to conservatism is
seeing the christian foundations for
this nation how our rights are given
from god not from government now i'd ask
you is as as a gay person how would that
seem appealing to you because you might
think oh well christianity says you know
i can't be this way so what would draw
you to and what how would you suggest
for like other gay people to say no this
is a good thing because it's we can we
this is just about giving us the freedom
to do whatever we can do and not shove
it on someone else i should have ended
on the hug
that would have been easier i should
have ended on the hug okay we got to do
it real quick i'll try to do it in 45
seconds uh well look this nation this
nation which is a nation founded on
judeo-christian principles is a nation
of individual rights that there are
going to be people here who live a
little bit differently than you and i am
not here to to try to destroy the
founding of this nation the core
principles of this nation i don't think
everyone has to be a christian i don't
think everyone has to be a jew or a
muslim but i think there are basic ideas
that our founders fully
fundamentally understood that we cannot
forget so what i would say is uh you are
absolutely entitled to your own personal
religious beliefs as everyone else's i
would say and maybe this is a little
more of the libertarian side of me but i
think this is totally congruent with
with the founders you want to have room
for the other people and if they live in
a way that is that is honest and decent
and defends their love of country and
does all of the things that are probably
pretty freaking close to the way you
live
then that is that is an extraordinary
country but it isn't easy to attain we
don't all come from the same place we
don't all eat the same foods we don't
all have the exact same accents or
clothes or dances or music but if we can
do that and again we've done it better
than anyone in the history of the world
if we can do that then i will also give
you the one second hug guys thank you
very much
thank you turning point you guys are
awesome appreciate it
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell